[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'année
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui peu le
sujet pour son essai l'extinction de
l'homme le projet fou des antispécistes
il y aurait également eu l'honneur
waeber pour son film il n'y aura plus de
nuit réalisé à partir d'imagés filmées
par les caméras thermiques des pilotes
d'hélicoptères de combat en irak et en
afghanistan c'est assez glaçant
vous allez voir et l'on terminera
l'émission avec le trompettiste nicolas
giraud pour l'album tempo tempo en
hommage au batteur nigérian tony allen
inventeur de l'afrobeat avec lequel il a
enregistré six albums et donné quantité
de concert et qui s'est éteint l'année
dernière à l'âge de 70 ans du 79 ans et
on commence tout de suite avec vous que
le sujet voici l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque des
animaux des dauphins oui alors des
dauphins qui se produisent ici en
spectacle dans l'un des trois parcs
animaliers qui faisait ce genre de
spectacle avec des cétacés
eh bien regardez attentivement cette
image vous ne la verrez plus sains tout
simplement parce que il ya actuellement
en cours d'examen à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat un projet de loi qui
est soutenu par la ministre actuelle de
l'environnement mais qui a été présenté
par des députés de la majorité et qui
vise à interdire tout simplement les
spectacles de cétacés dans les parcs
français ce qui veut dire que les
animaux qui étaient jusqu'à maintenant
en captivité vont probablement être
envoyés dans d'autres zoos en europe
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
sanctuaires marins qui permettrait de
les accueillir dans des conditions
suffisamment acceptable en france des
eaux qui n'auront pas de capacité
supplémentaire donc d'ailleurs y aurait
largement à dire sur la question du
bien-être animal sur cette décision
en tous les cas les députés ont voté en
première lecture ce texte estimant que
donc la place des dauphins n'est plus
dans un
un spectacle dans une arène et donc
c'est une évolution de notre regard sur
la dignité de l'animal est ce qu'il est
légitime ou pas d'assister à des
spectacles d'animaux comme à marineland
ou au parc astérix par exemple eh bien
c'est une question qu'on se posera
peut-être on parle de votre livre dans
un instant tout de suite comment son
le sujet vous êtes journaliste au figaro
vous publiez l'extinction de l'homme le
projet fou des antispécistes aux
éditions tallandier l'antispécisme
savais pas qu'une lubie intellectuelle
d'après vous c'est une véritable
révolution
oui en fait je me suis beaucoup étonné
quand je regardais les débats qui
tournait autour de la question animale
donc est-ce qu'on était pour
l'antispécisme contre est ce qu'on est
et vegan ou non en fait beaucoup de gens
me semble-t-il ne le prenez pas au
sérieux et disait ce sont des neuf sont
des allumés des gens qui veulent d'un
coup interdire l'élevage et la chasse ça
n'est pas sérieux
souvent on se moquait d'ailleurs de un
peu gentiment c'est ce qu'on continue de
faire dans un certain nombre de réunions
de famille où il maintenant il ya
toujours le beau frère ou la nièce qui
est reagan et qui commence à faire la
morale à tout le monde et souvent ça
suscite l'hilarité et moi j'ai pris le
parti au contraire de prendre très au
sérieux ce mouvement d'idées en entrant
dans une pensée très structuré un qui
fait maintenant depuis une cinquantaine
d'années référence dans beaucoup de
milieux intellectuels il ya une
production qui est très abondante et une
vraie littérature antispécistes il ya en
france aussi des revues maintenant qui
alimente aussi ses idées chaque été ils
se réunissent également en congrès ou en
université d'été il ya désormais aussi
un parti politique un parti animalistes
qui propulse la question de la
libération animale dans l'arène
politique
donc toutes ces raisons me font penser
que la cause animale et probablement
peut-être la cause la grande cause qui
va agiter le 21e siècle
en tous les cas dans les pays européens
et ça commence déjà on le voit bien avec
un regain d'activité notamment en france
de toutes ces associations animalistes
radical
on s'était habitués bien sûr à ce qui
est des militants qui oeuvrent pour le
bien-être animal la société protectrice
des animaux extra font un travail qui
est remarquable c'est pas le sujet mais
par contre à côté d'eux il ya maintenant
des associations qui propulse vraiment
la question de la faim de l'élevage de
l'abolition de l'élevage de la fin de la
chasse et qui en font un étendard
politique et ça connaît en france un
succès d'ailleurs assez tardif par
rapport à des pays anglo saxons il a
fallu peut-être vingt ou trente ans pour
que par exemple les grands best-sellers
de la littérature antispécistes soit
traduit en français maintenant c'est le
cas je crois qu'il ya un engouement
populaire pour cette question là on le
voit aussi avec les succès électoraux
que rencontrent les parties animalistes
qui
diffuser ses idées dans la sphère
politique et donc tout me semble
indiquer pour penser que nous allons de
plus en plus nous poser la question de
notre rapport aux animaux est dans sa
logique pendant que vous interrompre est
ce que ce n'est pas logique à partir du
moment où on a
abolie du moins en théorie toutes les
frontières qui existaient entre les
êtres humains entre les membres et les
non blancs entre les chrétiens et les
mécréants contre les nobles et les
roturiers entre les hommes et les femmes
entre les hétérosexuels et les
homosexuels aujourd'hui avec la crise
devant de l'environnement il semble
assez logique que ça s'étendent à tout
ce qui est vivant au fond sur je crois
que vous mettez brand le doigt sur
quelque chose de très juste à dire
qu'effectivement l'antispécisme est l'un
des nombreux avatars d'un mouvement
d'idées plus large qui est celui de la
pensée de la déconstruction déconstruire
c'est une idée qui n'est dans les années
70 dans les universités françaises ça se
répand dans l'ensemble des universités
européennes et même occidental l'idée
qu'au fond le réel n'est qu'une
projection de mes préjugés subconscient
et que donc j'ai inventé le réel de
façon artificielle et qu'il faut
maintenant de le déconstruire pour aller
voir quels sont les mécanismes de
domination qui se cache dessous
et donc c'est ce qui a conduit par
exemple une dimension peut-être
extrémistes du mouvement féministe a
dénoncé l'ensemble des interactions
sociales comme étant relié au patriarcat
cette espèce de main invisible de
l'homme sens masculin qui règnerait sur
l'ensemble du monde social et qui
imposera une forme de domination cacher
et bien de la même façon on déconstruit
une forme de domination caché qui
s'exprimerait à l'encontre de l'animal
et donc les antispécistes ont beau jeu
effectivement de dire que dans un monde
où l'on reconnaît que petit à petit les
différences s'estompent et que l'on ne
que l'on renonce à penser en termes de
nature et de données universel et bien
il est logique à ce moment-là de
déconstruire notre propre rapport à
l'animal est effectivement dans ces cas
là on n'est pas au bout de nos peines
puisque force est de constater que
jusqu'à maintenant dans les mentalités
commune on ne considère pas les animaux
comme on considère ses semblables et ses
voisins et donc pour les antispécistes
il ya là une forme de discrimination
injuste au nom de quoi des styles nous
aurions une préférence pour l'intérêt de
nos semblables
à l'exception de tous les autres animaux
non humains et je crois vraiment que ce
qui nous guette comme d'ange est une
immense confusion et notamment parce que
la question du bien-être animal est
nécessaire c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont contestables
dans la façon dont on élève les animaux
même dans certaines pratiques de chasse
ou d'abattage par exemple et que ce
débat-là ne sera pas possible tant qu'il
sera réquisitionnée par des militants
qui au fond ne prône pas l'amélioration
du bien-être animal meslin distinction
entre les intérêts humains les intérêts
animaux mais le fait d'ajouter des
droits aux animaux aux animaux qu'on
voit là en photo on a pris des photos de
d'exploitation animal c'est comme ça que
que ont peuplé les analyser ajouter les
droits aux animaux ne suppose pas dans
notés aux hommes
en fait c'est exactement l'argument que
j'essaie de démonter dans mon livre
c'est à dire que je ne prétends pas
pouvoir démontrer manière rationnelle ou
évidente que la dignité de l'homme est
supérieure à celle de l'animal quand on
parle de dignité on est dans l'ordre de
la philosophie pas de l'évidence
mathématiques en revanche là où il me
semble qu'à une erreur rationnel que
commettent les antispécistes ou
peut-être même une manipulation
hypocrite c'est de prétendre que les
intérêts des animaux peuvent être
augmentés sans qu'à un moment ou un
autre cela ne rejaillit sur ceux des
humains ça pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que très prosaïquement si
vous voulez prendre en compte davantage
les intérêts des animaux c'est à dire
que vous allez obstrué un certain nombre
de libertés humaines par exemple là dans
les débats qui nous concerne je vous ai
parlé à l'instant de marineland
oui et bien qu'il s'agit ici d'une
restriction apportée à la liberté
d'entreprendre au nom d'autres formes de
principe que le droit aurait à prendre
en compte c'est une job de la même
manière on nous interdira de manger des
animaux si j'ai bien suivi guy mollet
mais on interdira aux chasseurs d'aller
chasser dans la forêt et a donc toutes
ces restrictions peuvent s'entendre si
elles sont motivées par des principes
qui sont conséquents mais ici le
principe en question est celui d'une
d'un alignement du droit des animaux sur
les nôtres or déjà là c'est contestable
ensuite de cela quand on va commencer à
s'interdire par exemple à réguler la
population des animaux comprenez bien
que par exemple la régulation du gibier
que qu'opèrent les chasseurs dans les
campagnes françaises permet notamment de
préserver les cultures qui sinon
seraient piétiner si une prolifération
trop importante même façon les nuisibles
on commence à entendre par exemple à
strasbourg des élus municipaux d'hier en
conseil municipal
pouvons pas continuer à éliminer les
espèces nuisibles comme avant c'est à
dire de façon violente
nous devons réfléchir à des méthodes
alternatives alors tantôt on veut les
déplacer c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
créer des logements sociaux pour les
punaises de lit tente où on veut par
exemple leur proposer des méthodes de
contraception douce bon dans tous les
cas cela veut dire qu'on se compliquer
la tâche et on se prépare à vivre
davantage en compagnie d'animaux qui
menacent directement nos intérêts vous
êtes sur le plan politique et
effectivement il ya tout un il ya toute
une réflexion politique sur comment
donner des droits aux animaux on y
reviendra
mais au départ c'est d'abord c'est le
gentil s'épaississent tu veux élever
l'animal jusqu'à l'homme on lui on lui
reprend on lui répond et vous lui
répondez notamment qu'en fait il veut
abaisser l'homme jusqu'à l'animal et
pourquoi
oui c'est ce que je crains mais vraiment
pour la façon dont l'antispécisme
construit son rayonnement son
raisonnement philosophique en gros
l'antispécisme si je schématise c'est
quand peter singer en 1975 écrit la
libération animale c'est de dire nous
avons jusqu'à maintenant considérer que
le critère de l'espèce est un critère
morale pertinence à dire qu'on peut
avoir un comportement différent à
l'égard des cochons et des humains or je
considère que ce critère est
discriminant nous devrions au contraire
nous devrions considérer plutôt le
critère de la souffrance donc nous
allons élever à une sphère de
considérations morales tous les animaux
qui peuvent souffrir
or de ce point de vue là tout le monde
reconnaîtra que le cochon comme l'humain
ont à peu près les mêmes capacités à
souffrir et donc de ce point de vue là
il s'agit en fait d'une évolution de la
morale qui se préoccupent uniquement de
savoir si la somme de souffrance ou de
bien-être dans le monde est plus ou
moins grande voyez qu'en fait on a
amoindri la morale je crois pas du tout
qu une morale qui se propose comme seul
objectif de réduire la souffrance soit
proprement humaine
il me semble au contraire nous avons
justement par la richesse de notre vie
culturelle spirituelle nous avons élevé
la morale à des considérations et un
plus élevé d'ailleurs ya des formes de
souffrances qui sont tout à fait dignes
et tout à fait noble je pense aux
sacrifices que l'on fait pour protéger
son frère d'armes je pense à la douleur
de la mère qui enfin deux voiliers que
la souffrance par exemple c'est quelque
chose qui ne s'identifie pas
nécessairement au mal il ya des
différences une subtilité et donc en
fait on a réduit
l'acception que l'on à de l'humain et de
l'animal a une dimension purement
biologique
hic c'est à dire l'évitement de la
souffrance et la protection du bien-être
ce qui correspond à une vision très
bestial or la vie humaine n'est pas
seulement une vie biologique évidemment
que l'animal humain et existe dire que
nous sommes des animaux mais nous ne
sommes pas seulement des animaux nous
sommes des animaux alors les philosophes
vous diront tantôt sociable tantôt
politiques tantôt spirituel mais c'est à
dire que nous avons une forme de vie qui
ne correspond pas seulement la vie de la
matière et l'antispécisme justement
réduit la morale à la dimension
matérielle pour moi c'est un nouveau
matériel c'est à dire une idéologie qui
finalement ampute l'homme d'une part de
sa vie humaine pourquoi est-ce que ça
provoquerait l'extinction de l'homme
puisque c'est cela le titre
en quoi la protection de l'enfance
entraîne-t-elle light l'extinction des
adultes oui c'est effectivement une
remarque que m'ont fait certains
commentateurs sur les réseaux sociaux
alors en fait il faut bien comprendre
que ici le discours n'est pas simplement
un discours sur l'animal au sens
l'animal non humains mais sur l'ensemble
du monde animal voyez la protection de
l'enfance par exemple ne s'occupe que
des intérêts des enfants elle n'a pas un
discours sur l'adulte or le discours
antispécistes est un discours qui est
révolutionnaire en cela qu'il a une
vision complètement hégémonique du
vivant et qu'il ramène l'ensemble du
vivant à des intérêts primitif que sont
la souffrance et le bien-être et donc à
en quoi est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une
extinction de l'homme c'est à dire que
pour moi il s'agit d'un appauvrissement
de la conception que nous étions fait de
l'homme de ce qui avait été construit
dans l'anthropologie classique une
réduction en sommes à une part congrue
de notre humanité et j'en veux pour
preuve
voyez que l'antispécisme aient pu
conduire certains de ces têtes de fil à
des visions parfaitement dégradante de
la dignité humaine par exemple quand
vous demandez à peter singer s'il valait
mieux faire des expériences médicales
sur des animaux de laboratoire bien
portants ou sur des adultes humains
handicapé il préférait la seconde option
parce que pour lui les capacités des
adultes handicapées étant amoindrie leur
vie avec moins de valeur mais là je me
demande si on cite souvent cet exemple
j'ai pas lu peter singer dans le texte
mais je me demande s'il ne prenait pas à
rebours le raisonnement qui fait que
nous
sous prétexte que les animaux ne pense
pas on estime que leur dignité est
inférieur et que j'ai l'impression que
dans cet exemple là il laissé entendre
dans ces cas là les allées personnes
handicapées moteur ne pensons pas aussi
bien qu'à un dauphin il vaudrait mieux
faire des expériences sur eux que sur le
dauphin alors n'est ce pas singer s'est
pas fait la peau des expérimentations
sur les humains adultes handicapés
simplement ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que lui pour lui la vision qu'il a
de la dignité d'une vie n'est pas un
absolu c'est à dire que nous considérons
par exemple en défendant la démocratie
qui repose sur les droits de l'homme
nous considérons que la vie humaine est
sacrée quoi qu'il en soit quel que soit
ses capacités même la plus amoindrie
qu'elle soit par des formes terrible de
handicap ou de lésions nous considérons
qu'elle reste sacré qu'elle n'a pas de
prix pas de valeur et qu'il faut tout
faire pour pouvoir la sauver coûte que
coûte ce qui n'est pas le cas avec les
animaux on ne met pas en balance la vie
d'un animal avec la vie d'un humain ça
n'a pas de sens en tous les cas pas dans
nos conceptions évidemment c'est ce que
les antispécistes veulent changer
or peter singer lui raisonne
différemment il dit que l'intérêt d'une
vie peut presque se calculer à raison
des capacités de l'individu et que si
c'est un individu qui ne souffre pas par
exemple une carotte et bien la vie d'une
carotte n'a que très peu d'intérêt il
est légitime de la manger pour son
propre bien être
en revanche un cochon lui a la capacité
de 106 ans donc il a une vie un peu plus
évoluée voiliers et un adulte handicapés
ayant moins de capacités sa vie à mon
intérêt est par exemple peter singer et
là c'était tout sauf une boutade
ces fossiles défenseur de la vôtre
l'avortement par dans post natale en
disant que si on compare l'intérêt d'une
vie adulte très épanouie et d'une vie
tout juste sorti du sein de la mer est
bien la première prime sur la seconde
voyait est donc cette approche
capacitaire pour moi est complètement
déshumanisante dégradantes
or elle est justement le moteur de la
proche antispécistes et c'est à dire
c'est vraiment une remise en cause du
principe philosophique selon lequel la
vie humaine aurait une dignité
inaliénable et sacré mais quand on
regarde les vagues qui partent à
l'abattoir qui sont derrière vous on se
dit au fond si l'on admet qu'elle
partait l'abattoir pour finir dans notre
assiette
c'est parce qu'elle ne parle pas parce
qu'au fond on est bien on se dit
qu'elles doivent souffrir forcément on
n'est pas dupe on n'aime pas trop y
penser tout simplement mais on se dit
elle ne parle pas elle ne pense pas et
est à ce moment là des gens comme peter
singer ou d'autres animalistes vous
diront comme ça dépasse ça dépasse une
excuse que le bébé non plus ne parle pas
et que c'est pas une raison
ni pour le mans gêné pour faire des
expériences dessus donc le fait que ces
animaux ne parle pas au fond ça ne veut
rien dire
oui mais moi je ne prétend pas faire
reposer l'exception humaine sur la
capacité d'avoir la parole est
d'ailleurs par exemple ce sera un peu
délicat parce que je crois que ont fait
des expériences notamment sur les
passereaux qui sont des oiseaux qui ont
quasiment un langage articulé semblable
au nôtre
donc du point de vue scientifique de
toute évidence la spécificité de
l'espèce humaine ne correspond qu'à une
différence de degré et probablement pas
de nature nous sommes des animaux plus
évolué et plus avancé plus intelligents
mais cela ne suffit pas nous situer à
part du monde vivant au plan biologique
vraiment l' approche que je défends
c'est de dire que la biologie ne doit
pas épuiser le discours sur l'homme et
que donc ce n'est pas ni l' usage de la
parole ni l' usage des outils ni telle
ou telle autre spécificité de notre
espèce vraiment au plan strictement de
l'observation scientifique qui nous
isole et qui nous met à part du vivant
c'est justement la capacité que nous
avons à échapper à la tyrannie de la
biologie c'est à dire avoir une vie
culturelle avoir une histoire par
exemple voyez l'histoire c'est une
discipline à part c'est pas une science
dure mais le fait de se transmettre un
récit collectif de génération en
génération et de raconter les hauts
faits de ses aïeux est une capacité
propre à l'homme qui n'existe chez
aucune autre espèce animale et qui
repose justement sur notre capacité à
avoir une intelligence qui nous porte à
la dimension du sens or la souffrance
animale existait évidemment les animaux
ne parle pas mais il crie et je crois
que dans un abattoir il crie de façon
effroyable
évidemment c'est une forme de violence
dans la mise à mort de l'animal mais
cette souffrance-là n'a pas de sens au
sens où est
l'homme donne une signification à sa
douleur pas l'animal voyez c'est la
différence entre la douleur bestial et
la douleur animale
alors évidemment il ya quelque chose de
très inconfortable à faire souffrir des
animaux parce que personne au fond on
aime ça et d'ailleurs je crois pas que
ce soit de gaieté de coeur que le
personnel d'abattoirs les met à mort
simplement il s'agit d'une nécessité
vitale pour la survie de notre espèce et
l'on sait d'ailleurs que si l'on veut se
passer de viande on est obligé d'avoir
des méthodes de production alimentaire
qui sont beaucoup moins écologique que
celles qu'on utilise actuellement c'est
à dire que les vaches qui paissent dans
les troupeaux aujourd'hui alors certes
pète du méthane
mais enfin c'est quand même rien en
comparaison par exemple de la viande
artificielle qui se prépare dans des
laboratoires où là on cultive in vitro
des cellules moléculaire confesse
reproduire voyez donc il ya une forme de
nécessité dans la consommation de viande
qui n'est pas très confortable mais qui
repose sur le fait que l'homme a une vie
plus dense et une dignité qui repose sur
la capacité à élever sa vie à la
dimension du sens ce que n'ont pas les
animaux punch et le problème c'est que
au fond l'antispécisme et le véganisme
repose sur le refus de la violence et
sur le plan éthique
cette supériorité est indiscutable vous
aurez beau donner tous les arguments
philosophiques possible je suis sûr que
pour les gens de votre génération vous
avez 25 ans qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverts à ces idées que l'était ma
génération où la génération antérieure
j'ai l'impression que cet argument de la
non violence est un argument qui semble
décisif alors c'est vrai que vous avez
raison c'est à dire que si on compare
les valeurs qui sont prônées par
l'antispécisme et celles qui sont je
dirais porté par l'époque
tout y est et en ce sens c'est ce qui me
fait penser d'ailleurs qu'on n'a pas
fini d'entendre parler que
l'antispécisme a le vent en poupe alors
la question de la violence pour moi
justement est intéressante c'est à dire
que une fois encore d'une part je crois
pas que l'abolition de toute forme de
violence ou est un projet morale
suffisant voyez parce que il ya des
violences qui sont nécessaires et des
violence légitime on parle par exemple
du monopole de la violence légitime
quand on définit les prérogatives de
l'état cette violence-là est juste vous
voyez donc toute violence n'est pas
injuste en elle-même d'une part et c'est
important parce que sinon effectivement
on est dans la confusion morale la plus
absolue
mais là en l'occurrence sur des animaux
qui ne nous ont rien fait sans soir les
animaux qui nourrirait la question est
de savoir si cette violence-là est juste
ou si elle ne l'est pas et ensuite il ya
une autre question qui est de savoir si
elle est évitable
et je crois vraiment encore une fois
c'est des réflexions très personnel et
qui sont probablement difficile à
entendre surtout pour un jeune idéaliste
qui nous écoutent et qui au fond résonne
de façon très heureux très généreuse je
crois que l'homme s'est garé à mesure
qu'il se construit des raisonnements
moreau quasiment impossible par un
possible j'entends démiurgique voyez
c'est à dire que parfois l'homme ce rêve
presque en nouveau rédempteur du vivant
ou de l'univers on abolit dieu depuis
longtemps cela fait bien deux siècles
que plus personne ou presque n'y croit
et puis peut-être qu'on fait d'ailleurs
qu'on veut que les relevés les animaux
est rentable et cas c'est peut-être pour
ça que l'on se prend pour lui et que
l'on veut finalement être ceux qui vont
être en mesure de d'absoudre l'ensemble
de l'univers de toute la violence et de
tout le mal qui y règne or force est de
reconnaître que c'est au dessus de nos
forces
alors évidemment on pourrait peut-être
imaginer demain un monde où l'on se
passe nous humains de consommation de
viande ou de produits d'origine animale
mais nous ne sommes à priori pas les
seuls animaux prédateurs dans le vivant
en cercle les animaux aussi se mangent
entre eux donc là il ya aussi une forme
de violence est assez à leurs problèmes
que soulève un certain
d'ailleurs les antispécistes et
quelqu'un disant est ce qu'on laisse les
animaux continuer de se manger
absolument et c'est ce que demandent par
exemple thomas lepeltier lui il répond
par l'affirmative
donc un grand antispécistes français qui
nous disent il faudra réformer le jeune
homme des lions il faudra isoler les
gazelles il faudra leur donner des
compléments alimentaires à tous ces
prédateurs
thomas lepeltier pose la question avec
le lion et la gazelle ce sera autre
chose quand on ira à bord pour la
prédation au fond de l'océan par exemple
ce sera un peu plus compliqué mais vous
voyez qu'il ya quelque chose presque
d'aberrant pour la raison sert que de
penser que l'homme parce que moralement
il en à l'aspiration sera capable du
jour au lendemain de mettre fin à toutes
les formes de souffrance dans le vivant
c'est impossible mais la même façon que
je vous renvoie à une autre utopie
contemporaine qui est celle du
transhumanisme l'homme au fond on
aimerait vivre éternellement vivre en
tous les cas dans son corps biologique
mais là aussi ça le dépasser
probablement d'ailleurs en tous les cas
j'espère qu'ils n'en n'aura jamais les
moyens ce serait effrayant mais voyez
cette espèce de de contournement des
réalités biologiques où l'on voudrait
élargir la sphère de son esprit à
l'ensemble du vivant et se dire au fond
nous sommes capables d'être plus forts
que les lois de l'univers
eh bien je crois que
je parle ici à tous les jeunes
idéalistes qui nous regardent et qui
aspire généreusement à ce projet là je
crois qu'il faut savoir raison garder et
se dire que nous ne sommes pas à notre
place on nous décrit temps d'un instant
à l'autre les arbitres de l'ensemble du
bien et du mal dans l'univers et qu'il
faut savoir peut-être trouver des causes
un peu plus à notre mesure est par
exemple aujourd'hui moi je suis un peu
désarçonné quand je vois qu'on peut
s'investir avec autant d'ardeur dans la
cause animale alors qu'il reste encore
par exemple 10 millions de pauvres en
france qui aujourd'hui encore sont une
situation précaire surtout au sortir de
la crise qu vide voyez alors je ne nie
pas que les intérêts des animaux soit
important mais peut-être qu'à une
question priorité aussi est que lorsque
l'on aura d'abord régler les problèmes
des humains peut-être qu'il sera temps
de s'occuper de ceux des animaux
voyez mais là une autre question projet
que se pose peut-on libérer les animaux
est-ce qu'on peut sortir cetc de ces
deux fauves de leur cage est-ce qu'on
peut retirer leur laisse à nos chiens
est-ce que c'est possible
est ce que c'est possible d'en faire des
personnes avec des droits parce que
c'est ça que réclament les antispécistes
alors on sait bien qu'on peut avoir des
droits sans avoir toute sa raison c'est
le cadet des gens qui sont sous tutelle
c'est le cas des bébés ils n'ont ils ne
savent pas qu'ils votent mais quelqu'un
votre pour eux d'une façon ou d'une
autre et il les défend est ce que c'est
possible de les libérer
c'est à ça qu'on a qu'on appelle quand
on est en jeu c'est possible
certainement c'est à dire que sortir les
lions des cas je voyais ça se fait déjà
de relâcher des espèces sauvages alors
on les met rarement tout de suite dans
la nature on les met dans des
sanctuaires parce qu'en fait on se rend
compte qu'ils sont inaptes à la vie
sauvage et d'ailleurs les quelques fois
on a essayé de relâcher notamment des
orques dans l'océan ça s'est mal passé
pour eux ils ont
vécu très peu de temps ensuite mais
c'est rationnellement ça paraît
envisageable
après la question de la citoyenneté
c'est encore autre chose c'est
qu'effectivement vous citer une thèse
qui est explicitée dans ces eaux police
qui est vraiment le grand manifeste poli
fardeau politique des droits des animaux
dans lequel les auteurs distingue trois
catégories les animaux sauvages qu'il
faudrait laisser à part donc dans des
espèces de nation indépendante qui
serait défendu auprès de l'onu mais dans
lesquels l'homme n'aurait plus le droit
de mettre les pieds donc vraiment
complètement à part vous auriez les
animaux domestiques que acquis lourd
n'accorderait justement donc cette
citoyenneté qu'il faudrait d'ailleurs
éduquer c'est à dire il faudrait leur
incorporé quelques-uns de nos principes
ou des éléments centraux de notre mode
de vie pour s'assurer que leur
cohabitation ne soit pas hostile
donc ça veut dire je ne sais pas moi
peut-être fonder une éducation nationale
des chiens et des chats en tous les cas
admettons que ce soit une des pistes que
cela pourrait prendre
et puis vous avez tous ces animaux
liminaire que j'ai évoqué les pigeons
les rats les punaises de lit donc tous
ceux qui vivent au seuil de la vie
humaine mais qui ne sont pas domestiquée
par l'homme et qu'il faudrait
représentés dans nos conseils politiques
et nos assemblées pour être certain de
prendre systématiquement se pose
toujours
à la fin de tout ce raisonnement c'est
si on ne peut plus posséder ces chiens
il y en aura-t-il encore parce qu'à
partir du moment où ne plus plus
exploités l'animal ce qu'on ne peut plus
le posséder évidemment on se demande si
on lui laissera encore la possibilité de
n'être tout simplement m aujourd'hui des
millions d'animaux naissent uniquement
pour être mangés monument vous mettez le
doigt alors sur quelque chose que
l'antispécisme a pris très au sérieux
qui effectivement le fait qu' un certain
nombre d'espèces que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui serait probablement inapte à
une vie sauvage libérer du joug humain
c'est j'ose dire pour les antispécistes
c'est pas un problème très grave parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre qu'ils ne
sont pas écologiste en tous les cas pas
au sens où il est la société de façon
consensuelle sert que pour eux la
biodiversité n'est pas du tout une
préoccupation parce que la biodiversité
c'est la préoccupation des espèces or
eux ne s'intéresse pas aux espèces ils
sont antispécistes s'intéresse aux
individus et donc s'il faut que dans
cent ans nous ayons perdu la moitié des
espèces que nous connaissons parce
qu'elle serait tout simplement inapte à
une vie heureuse et agréable dans le
monde sauvage et bien tant pis au moins
justes ils les individus eux seront
heureux tant pis si l'on y perd la
moitié des espèces voiliers et c'est ce
qui fait la différence avec ma façon de
voir les choses qui est au contraire que
nous gagnons a justement préserver cette
richesse des espèces
par exemple à ce que l'homme a
effectivement une relation de domination
presque tyrannique sur le monde animal
et parce qu'il est de notre ressort et
peut-être même de notre responsabilité
d'entretenir cela est à linverse je
crois que justement c'est une approche
presque écologique des choses de
défendre encore et toujours le la
domination humaine sur l'animal parce
que seul homme est capable d'ordonner le
monde c'est à dire d'avoir une vision
architectonique du vivant et de mettre
chaque animal à sa juste place voyez
alors non pas qu'il y réussisse toujours
bien sûr on sait très bien que il peut
parfois dégradée certains de ses
équilibres mais il est le seul à avoir
une vision d'ensemble
or l'animal seul privée justement de
l'intelligence humaine n'en est pas
capable
donc je ne crois pas du tout qui est un
scandale pour la raison et encore moins
pour la morale a considéré que l'homme
est au centre de l'univers simplement
s'il est au centre il a des droits des
prérogatives mais il a aussi des devoirs
il faut qu'il soit à la hauteur de cette
responsabilité
l'extinction de l'homme le projet fou
des antispécistes c'est le titre de
votre livre 'le sujet qui vient de
paraître aux éditions tallandier
merci d'être venus dans cette émission
se retrouve dans un instant juste après
une pause avec la cinéaste
eléonore webber
[Musique]
et le nord vers vous êtes la
réalisatrice de il n'y aura plus de nuit
qui est sorti en salles le 16 juin un
film à la fois fascinant et angoissant
que vous avez fait à partir des images
filmées par les caméras thermiques des
pilotes d'hélicoptères de combat en irak
et en afghanistan dont on va regarder
tout de suite la bande-annonce mais
d'abord une image qui pour vous
symbolise notre époque
cette image là voici un alors pour moi
c'est un autoportrait de courbet mais
qui l'est pas il est pas très il est pas
tellement tiré de notre époque
c'est ce que vous ayez dire justement
j'ai choisi de montrer quelque chose qui
est dans toutes les images de notre
époque mais qu'on ne voit pas c'est le
regard justement faire dans ce flot
ininterrompu d'image il ya une
omniprésence du regard la effaré
halluciné on peut l'interpréter comme on
veut et je pense que ce regard structure
politiquement notre époque
voilà oui pourquoi de manière évidente
il la structure dans la société de
surveillance upa sèche prenait
l'ascenseur pour venir vous voir et je
vois que tu as well as les bureaux en
face des veaux très bon c'est l'entrepôt
20 la société qui finance tout nos
caméras de surveillance
ça c'est de la manière la plus évidente
mais aussi parce que se faire voir comme
la être vus m'apparaît comme un des
déterminants essentiels de notre vie en
société
d'autant plus intéressant que dans votre
film
on va en voir tout de suite la
bande-annonce en fait ces images filmées
par les pilotes d'hélicoptères de combat
en irak ou en afghanistan
c'est avec le regard que l'on filmé et
que l'on tire ah oui c'est avec le
regard qu'on vise qu'on filme et quand
il ya un couplage absolue entre la
caméra
le canon et et
il vise à revoir un go on regarde tout
de suite la bande-annonce d' il n'y aura
plus de nuit
ces images ne sont pas faites pour être
regardé les hélicoptères sont à des
kilomètres de leur cible
tout ce que les pilotes regarde à filmer
le chef de bord porte un casque
dirigeants la caméra de l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
ces mouvements de tête guide aussi le
canon mitrailleur
[Musique]
on est en pleine nuit
tout ce qui produit de l'achat le oui
[Musique]
côté vient d'opposer les pilotes ont par
ailleurs dû mal lorsque les corps
scintille à distinguer un paysan qui
porte un râteau sur l'épaule d'un
combattant avec une kalachnikov
plus ils voient
plus il risque de se tromper
c'est possible
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus aucune
contrainte
[Musique]
rien qui permette de juger ses propres
actes
[Musique]
on peut supposer que de temps à autre
dans le pays où l'on habite un pilote
nous observe
vous avez choisi la voix envoûtante et
en même temps assez marguerite duras
yens de nathalie richard pour faire la
voix off
il y avait une allusion à marguerite
duras dans votre esprit
non mais j'aime beaucoup marguerite
duras et on fait souvent ce
rapprochement je crois que c'est lui le
père wehinger appelé le pilote pierre v
ce type 2 non peut-être que j'avais
c'est un pilote avec qui vous avez
peut-être ont-ils eu mais qu'on n'entend
pas dans le film et qui s'appelle bien
évidemment pas pierre v alors peut-être
ça c'est comme un clin d'oeil à une
certaine manière d'inventer des noms
qu'avait duras et après c'est vrai que
j'ai choisi la voix de nathalie pour
deux raisons parce que c'est une voix
douce et elle me semblait pouvoir
accompagner là le paradoxe de ces images
qui sont requis qui montre une violence
terrible mais avec une douceur et un
éloignement qui est un amorti coup à
l'impact
donc j'ai aimé cette douceur là et puis
c'est vrai qu'elle est là quelque chose
peut-être qu'il fait penser ou chine de
duras ou en tout cas bon une voix de
récits tante marguerite duras yens
effectivement d'où sortent ces images
parce que c'est évidemment la première
question qu'on se pose en voyant ce film
ces images vous les ai prises où je les
ai toutes trouvées sur internet
elles sont en libre accès en réalité je
crois que qu'on les a tous vus plus ou
moins passé sans peut-être prendre le
temps de les regarder en tout cas moi
c'était mon cas j'avais pas pris le
temps de les regarder un jour je les
fais et
et j'ai pensé qu' il y avait là quelque
chose qui moi en tant que cinéaste ne
pouvait que perturbée au plus haut point
qu'une caméra soit est ce aussi un
projet un projet de mordre soit ce point
associé à un projet de mort est donc
alors cédé site
c'est youtube dailymotion des sites
commerciaux mais il ya aussi des sites
de vétérans de l'armée américaine sont
donc les pilotes eux-mêmes qui les
zombies puisque les pilotes sont tenus
d'enregistrer mon fils mais ils doivent
remettre les films ensuite à leur
hiérarchie et et ils le font sur une clé
usb donc on peut parfaitement imaginer
qu'ils ont mis eux mêmes des images sur
internet
non seulement on peut l'imaginer mais
c'est vraisemblablement le cas il le met
directement en effet de leur clé usb a
aussi deux sur lesquels il est publié
les raisons moi j'ai pas interroger ses
pilotes là mais ça semblait il semble
être assez fier de la mission qu'ils ont
accompli peut-être que ça sert une forme
de de propagande indirects et c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles
les états majors ne supprime pas ces
vidéos ce serait facile de l'ailette
circuler au fond ce soit la france ou
les états unis
ces deux pays sont fiers de ces missions
puisque on en a jamais rougis non mais
s'est dit fière d'avoir été en irak et
on attend mais après ce sont des images
en principe qui ne sont pas faites pour
être regardé qu'ils sont qui sont
classés secret défense sait pas c'est
moi gens comme cinéaste j'en ai fait des
images que l'on regarde comme on
regarderait des images de cinéma mais
pour le pilote avec qui je discutais il
comprenait pas cette position et 10 aces
et des images strictement opérationnels
qui servent à viser à tuer ce sont des
images sur lesquelles on suit des cibles
des cibles potentielles
on ne sait pas si ça va être une cible
ou pas le pilote souvent se pose la
question d'ailleurs on va voir tout de
suite un extrait où il se pose la
question mais on les suit à des
centaines de mètres voire à des
kilomètres et on n'entend pas un
ce que disent les gens mais on les voit
tellement bien c'est incroyable les gens
vous voulez dire les
les cibles lisible on l'est on les voit
et on ne les voit pas c'est quand même
des caméras qui devrait élucidé
absolument leur le réel et leur
sophistication devrait permettre de tout
voir mais on se rend bien compte avec
ces images qu'au fond les faits de
brillance des caméras thermiques voile
un peu là on voit que jamais leur visage
par exemple donc on les voit mais on ne
les voit pas son nez des fantômes
luminescents et surtout en effet on ne
les entend pas ça je pense que ce le
fait que ce soit des images muettes et
ce qui les rend les plus violentes quoi
enfin c'est ça la violence de ces jeux
qu'on n'a pas accès aux sons de l'autre
donc on a on est totalement coupée de
son altérité ou et on doit analyser ce
convoi pour décréter si cette personne
que l'on filmé la nuit un bien entendu
est hostile ou pas et on va voir par
exemple un extrait de votre film où
justement la question se pose comme
pratiquement à chaque fois on est en
pleine nuit peer v10 qui n'ont rien à
faire dans ce chan
et puis ils n'ont pas l'air si
tranquille
il y en a un qui s'est mis à courir et
un homme qui courent c'est ce qu'on
remarque le plus
lorsque je demande s'ils entendent
l'hélicoptère pierre v répond que oui
très certainement lorsque je demande
pourquoi il ne fut pas puisqu'il entend
d'hélicoptères pierre weill dit que ça
les rendrait encore plus suspect selon
lui ils font semblant d'être calme ces
sommes on va les voir mourir dans un
instant dans le film qui décide si on
tire ou pas est-ce que c'est le pilote
tout est ce que parce qu on entend aussi
des ordres dans la dans la carlingue du
monde ont ils sont 2 1 dans
l'hélicoptère le commandant de bord à la
responsabilité pénale de tirer mais
c'est pas lui qui donne l'autorisation
de tirer il ya toute une équipe bien
évidemment donc il a l'autorisation de
tir et ça c'est parce qu'ils ont analysé
des tas de choses il ya plusieurs
hélicoptères ya souvent une base et
quand il a l'autorisation de tirer il
dit quand même langage
enfin c'est lui qui enfin cette
responsabilité pénale elle est très
symbolique parce qu'il ya je crois pas
qu'il y ait beaucoup de procès remet en
tout cas c'est lui qui le décide c'est
le commandant de bord de tirer or il y
aussi bien pierre v que vous avez
interrogé
et vous dites qu'il est très difficile
de distinguer un combattant d'un civil
voire même une kalachnikov d'un râteau
il est trés plus plus il voit ses
pilotes là puis ils doutent et moi ils
sont sûrs de ce qu'ils voient ça c'est
une chose que m'a confirmé
le type avec qui j'ai discuté et c'est
une chose que moi j'analyse en regardant
ces images est la meilleure preuve c'est
quand même cette scène cette scène que
wikileaks a révélé où il interprète
d'état de forme pourtant il voit très
bien ils sont assez proches
c'est comme l'italie était mort un
journaliste
oui bah c'était un pied de caméra et
puissant isi ont vu donc en effet on se
trompe très souvent on n'est jamais sûr
de ce qu'on voit et donc sept sont des
images qui sont sujettes à une
interprétation infinie après on prend
régulièrement quand même la décision de
tirer tout est trop facile dit vous en
citant toujours pierre becker ce qu'il
entend par là quand il dit tout est trop
facile je crois qu'il parle de son
immunité
c'est à dire que tout et tout est facile
parce qu'ils ne risquent rien mais bien
sûr parce que les pilotes ne reste que
ne risque rien donc tirer ne pas tirer
n'a pas de conséquences immédiates sur
compte on risque toujours de se tromper
oui mais alors ça ça devient grave s'il
ya des conséquences au fait de s'être
trompée sinon ça n'est grave que pour
soi même enfin oui mais ça peut déjà
grave pour soi mais ça peut sans doute
produire des détournements et des
regrets c'est terrible quand on quand on
regarde
votre film c'est qu'on peut aussi se
mettre à la place de la cible et pas
seulement à la place de l'hélicoptère et
quand on est à la place de la cible on
se dit mais au fond non seulement on
peut me confondre avec un autre on peux
me prêter des intentions hostiles que je
n'ai pas mais surtout je ne peux pas me
cacher en tout cas dès l'instant je sors
on peut se cacher dans un bâtiment mais
pas à l'extérieur des bâtiments ils sont
au milieu du désert ils sont il fait
nuit noire et pourtant on les voit comme
en plein jour
oui c'est ça c'est en faire de l'oeil
sont venus de partout
non ça c'est notre cas ici aussi pour le
coup je pense que le film en effet pour
une en effet nous il nous plonge dans
l'oeil du viseur donc on est assigné à
la place du tueur une bonne partie du
film d'une certaine façon
moi j'ai fait en sorte qu'on puisse
penser cette place là qu'on n'y soit pas
totalement est signée justement mais on
peut aussi penser que ces silhouettes
luminescentes fait notre propre devenir
de citoyens ou de deux silhouettes
fantomatiques dans l'oeil du puits sans
fond moi j'ai fait un film sur les
images du pouvoir et sur la fonction des
guerres asymétriques sur les gâteaux et
du coup sûr ce qu'elle pouvoir donc
connaître les pilotes verticalité du
pouvoir et ça c'est doses sur le théâtre
des opérations c'est évidemment le cas
mais le tête des opérations c'est
souvent le laboratoire de ce qui passe
de l'exercice du pouvoir tout court et
de la manière dont on va dont on va le
mettre en oeuvre dans nos pays donc moi
je pense qu'on il ya quelque chose qui
nous fait nous mêmes que nous regardons
aussi dans ces images puisque vous
parlez des identifications possibles ya
quelque chose de cet ordre là et les
pilotes d'avions et d'hélicoptères qui
sont là n'ont jamais eu eux mêmes de
pilote d'hélicoptère au dessus d'eux sur
le gard asymétrique il ya quelques il ya
quelques images on voit que les
il se fait tout est filmé vous dit on
n'échappe pas au fait d'être vue d'être
regardé d'être filmés et parfois nous il
ya deux trois plans dans le film où un
hélicoptère film un autre hélicoptère
oui mais je veux dire par là que ses
pilotes aucun regard eu d'adversaire il
y avait la même technologie que ils se
sont jamais battus contre une armée qui
avaient les moyens de les battre et
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que ça fait
des décennies qu'il n'ya plus de guerre
ou de fait avec une arme et qui a les
mêmes moyens face à une autre dans nos
démocraties ses violons mènent des
guerres post coloniale d'une certaine
façon à n'en plus finir et les insurgés
que l'on combat sont très peu armés par
rapport à nous ça c'est la réalité
depuis des attaques on peut même se
demander si face à une armée elle est
même la même technologie que nous on ne
saurait encore se battre non mais
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué avec les
bombes atomiques non on ne se bat pas
will à ce qu'il n'y a plus il n'y a plus
de combats de ce type là et après ce que
vous soulignez en effet ces pilotes là
aucun zerg a aucun regard ne se portent
jamais sur eux c'est ça aussi qui qui a
qui fait que leur puissance est sans
limites et confine presque l impuissance
c'est à dire il ya ce fantasme de tout
voir qui celui de notre monde encore une
fois mais on voit bien dans le film
qu'il est qu'il est voué à l'échec en
fait que toujours quelque chose se
dérobe à la vue que on veut recréer un
un jour faut par exemple donc supprimer
cette dimension anthropologique de
l'existence que la nuit mais dans ce
jour faut tout en couleur comme ça les
étoile brille encore et donc résistent à
cette nuit américaine à l'envers donc il
ya une ambition folle de ces caméras qui
se mesure à la puissance divine ne peut
pas ne pas y penser
et puis il ya l'impuissance finalement
ça mène à une forme d'impuissance on se
trompe on perd les guerres parce
qu'aucune de ces gars là ne se gagne
puis elle continue tout le temps les
gens sont surarmés enfin c'est quand
même un ko et un drame absolu donc non
seulement du point de vue de la guerre
on la perd et du point de vue de la
puissance
on est dans un délire elle délirant elle
délire le réel ces caméras s'étaient
elles sont tellement puissante qu'elle
le dit
on a on n'a que des aberrations visuels
en gros on n'est plus dans le réel
une certaine façon c'est un film de
science-fiction qua non sens il n'y aura
plus de nuit c'est votre premier long
métrage à saint-léonard weber il est
sorti le 16 juin et c'est probablement
l'un des films les plus étonnants à voir
aujourd'hui
merci d'être venus merci à vous
[Musique]
nikon algéro vous vous êtes trompettiste
et vous sortez avec les cordes et une
liste fixée un album intitulé tempo
tempo en hommage au batteur tony allen
l'inventeur de l'afrobeat avec qui vous
avez longtemps travaillé tous les deux
qu'ils nous aient quitté les dernières à
l'âge de 79 ans l'image de notre époque
que vous avez choisi la voici qu'est ce
que ça représente
c'est la signature d'un artiste qui
s'appelle l'atlas alors c'est une qu'on
a pu utiliser c'était difficile de
trouver une image voilà moi je voulais
utiliser une image artistique
j'aime beaucoup cet artiste j'ai été
voir une exposition qui était destiné
aux enfants à la base et j'étais très
touché par par son travail
c'est quelqu'un qui a qui a été étudié
la calligraphie en au japon en chine et
dans les pays arabes
pendant de nombreuses années et qui
maintenant à une oeuvre que qui se
résume à de la calligraphie ou il ya
d'autres choses
mas et du street art c'est du street art
et oui c'est sa signature en fait ici un
peu de cette façon pour moi ce que
j'aime la danse et le mélange des
cultures en fait c'est cette synthèse
entre ces cultures ancestrales de
calligraphie et puis l'art urbain l'art
contemporain et on va regarder tout de
suite le clip de la vie est belle
une chanson tirée de l'album tempo de
tempo majeur atelier allen on vous y
voit avec fixie l'accordéoniste et avec
joe joe à aller la vie est belle
[Musique]
remercions nos aînés sont tombés nous
avons remonté
ce salon
[Musique]
angers
à
ses copains
tous
le clip est réalisé par olivier loustau
mais est ce que c'est la batterie de
tony allen qu'on entend c'est la
batterie de tony allen
alors vous avez joué beaucoup avec lui
tony allen s'est d'abord c'est
l'inventeur de l'afrobeat avec fela kuti
alors l'inventeur de on va dire presque
de la partie rythmique delà de la petite
batterie puisque fait l'a été quand même
un grand compositeur il avait même
étudier en angleterre dans les écoles de
musique et il était très directif et il
allait voir chaque musicien et des
toitures jousse as toi tu joues ça toi
tu vois et quand ils arrivent à être
tony dit toi tu joues ce que tu veux et
et c'était toujours voilà tony c'est un
génie donc il y avait toujours quelque
chose d'inattendu qui sortait de sa
batterie jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à ses
derniers albums
quand vous étiez sur scène avec lui
est-ce qu'il vous regarde est ce que
vous le regardez comment ça se passait
beaucoup beaucoup il voulait toujours
regarder les cuivres non moi je t'ai
toujours son côté son côté gauche parce
que des fois la cymbale elle va cacher
un peu il va chercher mais la charleston
la batterie les cuivres et puis surtout
il nous regardait surtout au début
pour faire référence à l'album ils nous
regardent et hoda avant le concert et
avant de monter sur scène on disait
tempo tempo ça veut dire quoi tempo
tembo lors le type et le rythme oui bien
sûr mais avec quel sens pour lui bassett
et que c'était très important
le rythme le rythme parce que pour lui
la musique c'était c'est comme une
thérapie c'est quelque chose qui devait
nous nous remettre en harmonie c'était
quelque chose de joyeux alors il y avait
des messages des fois il y avait des
messages il parlait de du mal-logement
de de la discriminer de la
discrimination ou il en a parlé mais des
luttes sociales
mais bon c'était toujours fait quand
même pour pour danser et pour célébrer
on va regarder tout j'étais un extrait
de du clip silhouette agent morceaux de
thoniers haleine donc va le voir dans ce
clip
et puis surtout malentendu on va
entendre cette rythme très particulier
qui a été levée
ouais
[Musique]
tous
oh
stade jeunes c'est un album qui date de
2009 qui a été réalisé par fixie on
vient de vous voir vous entrevoir
entrevoir sur le canard vous jouiez
évidemment sur l'album en revanche il ya
beaucoup d' images qui sont des images
d'archivés en france doivent dater des
années 70 au nigeria lagos à souvenirs
de cet album plus particulièrement alors
l'enregistrement d'albums
parce que moi je n'avais pas écouté les
maquettes j'avais rien écouter donc fixe
y travaillait un peu en secret tony
l'aimé bien travaillé il avait réalisé
deux albums avec fixie au moins au moins
deux j'ai pas tout et il aimait bien
travaillé même en secret personnes
savaient ce qu'ils faisaient donc ils
allaient le soir sa fille qui traita
chez un compositeur fâcher un
réalisateur et travailler aux maquettes
et nous appeler au dernier moment pour
aller pour aller faire l'album
donc je me suis on est arrivé on n'avait
rien entendu et puis nous chantait les
phrases de cuivre cette phrase qui nous
qui nous chantait et il n'y avait pas de
partition et aériens et puis il fallait
fallait refaire on a découvert la
chanson et c'est est ce que vous avez
décidé de faire un album hommage avec ma
fic si comme vous êtes pris comment vous
vous êtes dit uniquement on va utiliser
la batterie de 2
de tony allen les enregistrements qu'on
a ou en fait en fait oui un autre
message à l'intérieur il ya plein de
choses il a beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup
d'émotion il ya beaucoup de vécu
on a c'est pas ça c'est que tony c'était
comme un père un peu pour nous c'est que
fixe il voyait beaucoup en dehors moi
moi j'étais tout le temps j'ai fait
toutes les tournées quasiment avec lui
et il y en avait une relation dans le
regard et il me disait tout le temps à
moi comme un fixie fait-on fait-on
projet je serai là pour toi j'ai il faut
que tu il faut dépêcher quoi on n'est
pas éternel donc la dernière fois qu'il
est venu chez moi c'était en février et
on avait commencé un peu à travailler
avec fixie fixe était venu à dans mon
studio et on s'était dit là il faut
qu'on l'a faut qu'on mette en pratique
ce que tony nous demande donc on a
commencé à faire des maquettes
j'ai vu tony et je lui ai fait écouter
et me dit ben semaine prochaine je viens
on commence on commence à travailler il
ya eu le confinement juste à ce moment
là donc on s'est revu après le après le
décès de tony et après le confinement
donc du coup on vient on avait beaucoup
d'eux beaucoup de tristesse déjà et puis
une grande envie de faire cet album
d'aller au bout d'aller au bout de ce
qui nous avait demandé de faire grève et
partir tourner oui ouais sans lui sans
lui avec un petit peu parce qu'on joue
quand même sur ses batteries
en fait on a on a voulu jouer avec des
ias 1 2 batteurs qui pourraient l'imiter
mais l'original c'est quand même c'est
quand même lui donc on fait un espèce de
demix acoustique électro un petit peu
enfin voilà il faut venir nous voir au
café de la danse le 16 novembre
c'est le 7 novembre oui et pendant l'été
vous serez en france non l'album vient
juste de sortir donc donc là on
celle là les démarches pour aussi de
pour la tournée commence là donc on a
une résidence on a des dates qui arrive
mais c'est pour l'automne et puis 2020
quelque et le batteur l'avait inspiré ce
qui le disaient ce qu'ils en parlent et
ceux qui l'avait piqué 2 3 trucs a
commencé à bloquer leurs attaques et il
lui a fait un album mais voilà un
tribute
non je pensais au mari de dab et lincoln
mais je suis tout à coup son nom mais
j'ai la croupe à nonant un très grand
batteur mais ça me revenir mais est-ce
qu'il incitait lui will ans si tu es
mais surtout ce qui la particularité de
tony et là où il a été un artiste unique
c'est que c'est que très très tôt très
très jeune il s'est dit si je veux me
faire remarquer si il faut que j'aie mon
propre style donc ça tout le monde se le
dit mais tour y réfléchira quand le jazz
et c'est difficile parce que la batterie
on a la grosse caisse la caisse claire
le charlet on n'a que trois éléments
moi j'aurais du mal à reconnaître un
batteur d'un autre batteur par contre
tony allen alors bon je suis pas je suis
un peu parti est prenante
je le reconnais tout de suite tout mot
sernhac scotch un max roach ou est à
très grande à très bon batteur un grand
compositeur et arrangeur il ya une
politique qui lui avait piqué quelques
trouées ouais il ya une petite anecdote
tony a commencé très tard la batterie en
19 ans comme ça et donc il était sûr
montrer très très doué et un jour ils
l'ouvrent un magazine de jazz où il y
avait un espèce de commun aujourd'hui à
youtube et les tutoriels mais là il y
avait les conseils de max roach je
croise presque sûr que c'était max roach
est justement et à droite de la batterie
à un charleston et dans le jazz le
charleston il fait swinguer y fait un
deux trois quatre
donc on appuie sur le charleston et donc
lui il a travaillé pour adapter les
rythmes de ilife épices sont cc pattern
à lui en rajoutant ce côté swing qui est
très très subtil alors c'est pas aussi
prononcée que dans le jazz où on entend
vraiment le swing 2 et 4 ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon de musiciens mais
il a ajouté ça et c'était vraiment une
anecdote qui racontait souvent tempo
tempo
c'est l'album de nicolas giraud et 2
si tony allen cbb shon et puis vous
serez vous au café de la danse le 15 9
en 16 le 16 novembre pardon merci
nicolas giraud d'être passé par cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]